ah bravo quel bonheur ils ont bien la
pêche c'est pour ça comment tu veux que
j'en parle faut regarder cette émission
vaut vraiment le coup les mecs ils ont
tu sais ce qui serait bien là en train
d'attendre que tu les fasses venir et
qu'on les voit là tout de suite là comme
ça
si j'étais là
on passe au blender
je vous présente le Comédie Club
présentez-vous les gens après les autres
je commence par quoi
[Musique]
dictateur dans son pays c'est sûr je
pense sur
une blanche alors on a fait venir
blanche bien joué tu t'appelles comment
Amel
Fabrice pas de sonne jazz dos qui boit
un litre de sang humain par jour
et Sami dit le conte de Bouderbala
donc vous aurez le privilège de
retrouver cet été sur Canal+ j'espère
que vous serez nombreux à regarder cette
émission à vaut le coup et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de Inna larditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu